you may have heard the phrase the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics in the Natural Sciences this
was the title of a paper by the
physicist Eugene wigner but even more
fun than the title is the way that he
chooses to open it the paper begins
quote there is a story about two friends
who were classmates in high school
talking about their jobs one of them
became a statistician and was working on
population Trends they showed a reprint
to their former classmate and the
reprint started as usual with the
gaussian distribution the statistician
explained to the former classmate the
meaning of the symbols for the actual
population the average population and so
on the classmate was a bit incredulous
and was not quite sure whether the
statistician was pulling their leg how
can you know that was the query and what
is this symbol over here oh said the
statistician this is pi what is that the
ratio of the circumference of a circle
to its diameter well now you're pushing
the joke too far said the classmate
surely the population has nothing to do
with the circumference of a circle
in the paper wigner then goes on to talk
about the more General phenomenon of
Concepts in pure math seeming to find
applications that extend strangely
beyond what their definitions would
suggest but I would like to stay focused
on this particular anecdote and the
question that the statistician's friend
is getting at you see there is a very
beautiful and classic proof that
explains the pie inside the formula for
a normal distribution and despite there
being a number of other really great
explanations online see some links in
the description I cannot help but
indulge in the pleasure of reanimating
it here
for one thing there is a fun side note
that I didn't learn until recently about
how you can use this proof to derive the
volumes of higher dimensional spheres
but much more importantly than that what
I really want to do is try to go beyond
the classic proof consider this
hypothetical statistician's friend what
I want to ask is can we find an
explanation that would satisfy their
disbelief you see they're not just
asking for some pure math proof about a
function that was handed down to them on
high the friends in credulity was that
circles should have anything to do with
population statistics until we fully
draw that connecting line we should
consider the task incomplete those of
you who watched the last video on the
central limit theorem will have some of
the backdrop here because there we broke
down the formula for a normal
distribution which is also called a
gaussian distribution and when you strip
away all of the different parameters and
the constants the basic function that
describes the bell curve shape is e to
the negative x squared and the reason
that Pi showed up in the final formula
was that the area underneath this curve
works out as you will see in a couple
minutes to be the square root of pi
so what that meant for us was that at
some point we needed to divide out by
that square root of Pi to make sure that
the area under the curve is one which is
a requirement before you can interpret
it as a probability distribution
in the full formula that you would see
say in a stats book this gets mixed
together with some of the other
constants but in its purest form that Pi
originates from the area underneath this
curve
so step number one for you and me is to
explain that area but I want to
emphasize it's not the last step to
satisfy the question raised by that
hypothetical statistician's friend we
need to go further we need to also
answer why is it that this function e to
the negative x squared is so special in
the first place I mean there are lots of
different formulas you could write down
that would give a shape that you know
vaguely bulges in the middle and tapers
out on either side so why is it that
this specific function holds such a
special place in statistics to phrase
our goal another way can we find a
connection between the proof that shows
why Pi shows up and the central limit
theorem which as we talked about in the
last video is the thing that explains
when you can expect a normal
distribution to arise in nature
so with all of that as the goal first
things first let's dig into the classic
and very beautiful proof
[Music]
all right when you want to find the area
underneath a curve the tool for doing
that is an integral as a quick reminder
for how you might read this notation you
might imagine approximating that area
with many different rectangles under the
curve where the height of each such
rectangle is the value of the function
above that point in this case e to the
negative x squared for a certain input X
and the width is some little number that
we're calling DX
we need to add up the areas of all these
rectangles for values of X ranging from
negative Infinity up to infinity and the
use of that notation DX is kind of meant
to imply you shouldn't think of any
specific width but instead you ask as
the chosen width for your rectangles
gets thinner and thinner what does this
sum of all those areas approach of
course all of that is just notation
unless you provide a way to answer that
question and the magic of calculus is
that it provides just that at least
usually you see usually the procedure
here would be to find some function
whose derivative is equal to the stuff
we have on the inside e to the negative
x squared in other words we want to find
an antiderivative of that function the
problem is for this particular function
it is provably not possible to find such
an antiderivative
it's a little weird and Beyond the scope
of what I want to talk about here but
basically even though there exists an
anti-derivative it is a well-defined
function you cannot express what that
anti-derivative is using all our usual
tools like polynomial Expressions trig
functions exponentials or any way to mix
them together so finding this area
requires a bit of cleverness there needs
to be a new trick that we bring to bear
and the first step to this trick is
easily the most absurd we start by
bumping things up one dimension so that
instead of asking for the area under a
bell curve we ask for the volume
underneath this kind of bell surface
you could rightly ask why would you do
that who ordered another dimension and
I'll admit it's not terribly motivated
right now other than to say watch what
happens when we just try it and in
general with hard problems it's never a
bad idea to try solving cousins of the
problem since that can help you get a
little bit of momentum and insight
to be clear on how this higher
dimensional function is defined it takes
in two different inputs X and Y which we
might think of as a point on the X Y
plane and the way to think about it is
to consider the distance from that point
to the origin which I'll label as R and
then to plug in that distance to our
original bell curve function that is we
take e to the negative r squared you
might notice the lines I've drawn on
this diagram make a right triangle so by
the Pythagorean theorem x squared plus y
squared equals r squared so in the
function I have written where you see x
squared plus y squared you can think in
the back of your mind that's really the
square of the distance from the point to
the origin the main thing to notice here
is how this gives our function a kind of
circular symmetry in the sense that all
of the inputs that sit on a given Circle
have the same output and so when we
graph this function in three dimensions
it means it has a rotational symmetry
about the z-axis
math tends to reward you when you
respect its symmetries so for our
question of computing the volume
underneath the surface what we're going
to do is respect that Symmetry and
imagine integrating together a bunch of
thin little cylinders underneath that
surface
here making this a little more
quantitative let's focus on just one of
those cylindrical shells where its area
is going to be the circumference of that
shell times the height you might imagine
it as something like the label on a soup
can that we can unwrap into a rectangle
the circumference of the cylinder which
is the top side of that rectangle is
going to be 2 pi times the radius
and then the height of our cylinder the
other side of our rectangle is the
height of the surface at this point
which by definition is the value of our
function associated with that radius
which like I said earlier you can think
of as e to the negative r squared
now the real way you want to think about
this is to give that cylinder a little
bit of thickness which we'll call Dr so
that the volume that it represents is
approximately that area we just looked
at multiplied by this thickness Dr our
task now is to integrate together or add
together all of these different
cylinders as R ranges between 0 and
infinity or more precisely we consider
what happens as that thickness gets
thinner and thinner approaching zero and
we add together the volumes of the many
many many different thin cylinders that
sit underneath that curve
you might think this is just a harder
version of what we were looking at
earlier three dimensions should be more
complicated than two
but actually something very helpful has
happened first let me clean up a little
by factoring the pi outside that
integral now the stuff inside that
integral having picked up this term 2R
does have an anti-derivative we can now
apply the usual tactics of calculus
specifically that whole inside
expression is the derivative of negative
e to the negative r squared and so those
of you comfortable with Calculus know
what to do from here we take that
anti-derivative and plug in the upper
bound which is negative infinity squared
and that gives us 0 or speaking a little
bit more precisely if you consider the
limit of this expression as the input
approaches Infinity the limiting value
is zero and we subtract off the value of
that anti-derivative at the lower bound
0 which in this case is negative one so
all in all the whole integral just works
out to be one which means all we're left
with is that factor out in front pi
evidently the volume underneath this
Bell surface is pi
and I'll point out in this case it's not
wild that Pi shows up because the
surface has this intrinsic circular
symmetry
still you might wonder how does that
help us as I said throughout math if you
face a hard problem solving an adjacent
problem can be unexpectedly helpful as a
next step and in this case it's helpful
not just for building intuition but we
can directly relate the
three-dimensional graph to our
two-dimensional graph by analyzing the
volume in a second different way
you see the more General way to approach
volumes underneath surfaces is to think
of chopping it up into slices that are
all parallel to one of the axes for
example all these slices that are
parallel to the x-axis
for example this right here is a slice
that corresponds to the plane y equals
zero you might notice it looks just like
a bell curve and if we write out the
function this should actually make a lot
of sense you could just plug in y equals
zero but to help see what happens with
other slices notice how thanks to the
rules of exponentiation we could also
write our function as e to the negative
x squared times e to the negative y
squared it factors out nicely
on this slice that e to the negative y
squared is just a number specifically
the number one so this is the same graph
we've seen before e to the negative x
squared meaning that the area of this
slice is exactly the thing that we're
looking for it's the mystery constant
which I'm going to give the name c
what's nice is there's nothing really
special about this particular slice if
we chose a different slice corresponding
to a different y value it corresponds to
multiplying this curve by a different
number so it's the same basic shape just
scaled down by that number meaning its
area is the same as our mystery constant
just scaled down by some number that's
pretty cool each one of these slices has
the same basic shape just rescaled in
the vertical Direction
which by the way is not at all true for
most two variable functions this is very
much dependent on the fact that we were
able to factor our function into one
part that's just dependent on the Y and
another part that's just dependent on
the X
now to think about the volume underneath
this whole surface here's another way we
could phrase it we're going to compute
another integral that ranges from y
equals negative Infinity up to Infinity
where the term inside that integral
tells us the area of each one of those
slices and when we multiply it by a
little thickness d y you might think of
it as giving each one of those slices a
little bit of volume and remember that
term C sitting in front represents the
thing we want to know which itself is an
integral a suspiciously similar looking
integral
see if we take the expression on the top
and we factor out that constant C
because it's just a number it doesn't
depend on y the thing we're left with
the integral we need to compute is
exactly the mystery constant the thing
we don't know
so overall the volume underneath this
Bell surface works out to be this
mystery constant squared
out of context this might seem very
unhelpful it's just relating one thing
we don't know to another thing we don't
know
except we've already computed the volume
under this surface we know that it's
equal to Pi therefore the mystery
constant we want to know the area
underneath this bell curve must be the
square root of pi
it's a very pretty argument but a few
things are not entirely satisfying for
one thing it feels a little bit like a
trick something that just happened to
work without offering much of a sense
for how you could have rediscovered it
yourself also if we think back to our
imagined statistician's friend it
doesn't really answer their question
which was what do circles have to do
with population statistics
like I said it's the first step not the
last and as our next step let's see if
we can unpack why this proof is not
quite as wild and arbitrary as you might
first think and how it relates to an
explanation for where this function e to
the negative x squared is coming from in
the first place
foreign
was this mathematician scientist slash
inventor who really did all sorts of
things throughout the 19th century he
made contributions in chemistry
astronomy photography botany he invented
the blueprint and named many of the
moons in our solar system and in the
midst of all of this he also offered a
very elegant little derivation for the
gaussian distribution in 1850.
the setup is to imagine that you want to
describe some kind of probability
distribution in two-dimensional space
for instance maybe you want to model the
probability density for hits on a
dartboard what Herschel showed is that
if you want this distribution to satisfy
two pretty reasonable seeming properties
your hand is unexpectedly forced and
even if you had never heard of a
gaussian in your life you would be
inexorably drawn to use a function with
the shape e to the negative x squared
plus y squared you do have one degree of
freedom to control the spread of that
distribution and of course there's going
to be some constant sitting in front to
make sure it's normalized but the point
is that we're forced into this very
specific kind of bell curve shape
the first of these two properties is
that the probability density around each
point depends only on its distance from
the origin not on its direction so on a
dartboard with everybody aiming for the
bullseye this would mean that you could
rotate the board and it would make no
difference for the distribution
mathematically this means that the
function describing your probability
distribution which I'll call F2 since it
takes in two inputs X and Y while it can
be expressed as some single variable
function of the radius r
and just to spell it out R is the
distance between the point x y and the
origin the square root of x squared plus
y squared
property number two is that the X and Y
coordinates of each point are
independent from each other which is to
say if you learn the x coordinate of a
point it would give you no information
about the y-coordinate
the way this looks as an equation is
that our function which describes the
probability density around each point on
the X Y plane can be factored into two
different parts one of which can be
purely written in terms of X this is the
distribution of the x coordinate I'm
giving it the name G and the other part
is purely in terms of Y this would be
the distribution for the y-coordinate
which I'm temporarily calling H but if
you combine this with the assumption
that things are radially symmetric both
of these should be the same distribution
the behavior on each axis should look
the same so we could also write this as
G of x times G of Y it's the same
function and more than that this
function is actually going to be
proportional to the one we were just
looking at the one that describes our
probability density as a function of the
radius the distance away from the origin
to see this imagine you were to analyze
a point that was on the x-axis a
distance R away from the origin then the
two distinct ways to express our
function based on the two different
properties tells us that F of R has to
equal some constant multiplied by G of R
so these functions f and g are basically
the same thing just up to some constant
multiple
and you know what it would be really
nice if we could just assume that that
constant was 1 so that f and g were
literally the same function and what I'm
going to do which might feel a little
bit cheeky is just assume that that is
the case what this means is that our
answer is going to be a little bit wrong
the function that we will deduce
describing this distribution will be off
by some constant Factor but that's no
big deal because in the end we can just
rescale to make sure the area under the
curve is one like we always do with
probability distributions now if f and g
are the same thing this gives us a very
nice little equation purely in terms of
the function f
remember what this function f is if you
have some point in the X Y plane a
distance R from the origin then F of R
tells you the relative likelihood of
that point showing up in the random
process more specifically it gives the
probability density of that point at the
outset this function could have been
anything but herschel's two different
properties evidently imply something
kind of funny about it which is that if
we take the X and Y coordinates of that
point on the plane and evaluate this
function on them separately taking f of
x times F of Y it should give us the
same result or if you prefer we could
expand out the meaning of that distance
r as the square root of x squared plus y
squared and this is what our key
equation looks like
this kind of equation is what's known in
the business as a functional equation
we're not solving for an unknown number
instead we're saying that the equation
is true for all possible numbers X and Y
and the thing we're trying to find is an
unknown function
in the back of your mind you can think
we already know one function that
satisfies this property e to the
negative x squared and as a sanity check
you might verify for yourself that it
does satisfy that
of course the point is to pretend that
you don't know that and to instead
deduce what all of the functions are
which satisfy this property
in general functional equations can be
quite tricky but let me show you how you
can solve this one
first it's nice to introduce a little
helper function that I'll call H of X
which will be defined as our mystery
function evaluated at the square root of
x set another way h of x squared is the
same thing as f of x
for example in the back of your mind
where you know that e to the negative x
squared will happen to be one of the
answers this little helper function H
would be e to the negative X but again
we're pretending like we don't know that
the reason for doing this is that the
key property for f looks a little bit
nicer if we phrase it in terms of this
helper function H because now what it's
saying is if you take two arbitrary
positive numbers and you add them up and
evaluate H it's the same thing as
evaluating h on them separately and then
multiplying the results in a sense it
turns addition into multiplication some
of you might see where this is going but
let's take a moment to walk through why
this forces our hand
as a Next Step you might want to pause
and convince yourself that if this
property is true for the sum of two
numbers this property also must be true
if we add up an arbitrary number of
inputs
to get a feel for why this is so
constraining think about plugging in a
whole number something like h of 5.
because you can write five as one plus
one plus one plus one plus one this key
property means that it must equal h of 1
multiplied by itself five times
of course there's nothing special about
five I could have chosen any whole
number n and we'd be forced to conclude
that the function looks like some number
raised to the power n
then let's go ahead and give that number
a name like B for the base of our
exponential
as a little mini exercise here see if
you can pause and take a moment to
convince yourself that the same is true
for a rational input that if you plug in
P over Q to this function it must look
like this base B raised to the power p
over Q
and as a hint You might want to think
about adding that input to itself Q
different times
and then because rational numbers are
dense in the real number line if we make
one more pretty reasonable assumption
that we only care about continuous
functions this is enough to force your
hand completely and say that H has to be
an exponential function B to the power x
for all real number inputs X I guess to
be more precise I should say for all
positive real inputs the way we defined
H it's only taking in positive numbers
now as we've gone over before instead of
writing down exponential functions as
some base raised to the power x
mathematicians often like to write them
as e to the power of some constant c
times x making the choice to always use
e as a base while letting that constant
C determine which specific exponential
function you're talking about just makes
everything much easier anytime calculus
comes wandering along your path
and so this means that our Target
function f has to look like e to the
power of some constant times x squared
the duty is that that function is no
longer something that was merely handed
down to us from on high instead we
started with these two different
premises for how we wanted a
distribution in two Dimensions to behave
and we were drawn to the conclusion that
the shape of the expression describing
that distribution as a function of the
radius away from the origin has to be e
to the power of some constant times that
radius squared
you'll remember I said earlier this
answer will be off by a factor of a
constant we need to rescale it to make
it a valid probability distribution and
geometrically you might think of that as
scaling it so that the volume under the
surface is equal to one
now you might notice that for positive
values of this constant in the exponent
C our function blows up to Infinity in
all directions so the volume under that
surface would be infinite meaning it's
not possible to renormalize you can't
turn it into a probability distribution
and that leaves us with the last
constraint which is that this constant
in the exponent has to be a negative
number and the specific value of that
number determines the spread of the
distribution
Ten Years After Herschel wrote this
James Clerk Maxwell who's most well
known for having written down the
fundamental equations for electricity
and magnetism independently stumbled
across the same derivation in his case
he was doing it in three dimensions
since he was doing statistical mechanics
and he was deriving a formula for the
distribution for velocities of molecules
in a gas but the logic all works out the
same
for you and me if we view this as the
defining property of a gaussian then
it's a little bit less surprising that
Pi might make an appearance after all
circular symmetry was part of this
defining property more than that it
makes the clever proof that we saw
earlier feel a little bit less out of
the blue I mean a key problem solving
principle in math is to use the defining
features of your setup and if you had
been primed by this Herschel Maxwell
derivation where the defining property
for a gaussian is this Coincidence of
having a distribution that's both
radially symmetric and also independent
along each axis then the very first step
of our proof which seemed so strange
bumping the problem up one dimension was
really just a way of opening the door to
let that defining property make itself
visible
and if you think back the essence of the
proof came down to using that radial
symmetry on the one hand and then also
using the ability to factor the function
on the other
from this standpoint using both those
facts feels less like a trick that
happened to work and more like an
inevitable necessity
nevertheless thinking once again of our
statistician's friend this is still not
entirely satisfying using the Herschel
Maxwell derivation saying this property
of a multi-dimensional distribution is
what defines a gaussian well that
presumes that we're already in some kind
of multi-dimensional situation in the
first place much more commonly the way
that a normal distribution arises in
practice doesn't feel spatial or
geometric at all it stems from the
central limit theorem which is all about
adding together many different
independent variables so to bring it all
home here what we need to do is explain
why the function that's characterized by
this Herschel Maxwell derivation should
be the same thing as the function that
sits at the heart of the central limit
theorem
and at this point those of you following
along are probably going to make fun of
me I think it makes sense to pull this
last step out as its own video I realize
this is what the third time in a row
that I've kicked this particular can
down the road you see the thing I'm
building up to here involves a
combination of the topics from the last
three videos convolutions the central
limit theorem and now the Herschel
Maxwell characterization of normal
distributions
the traditional explanation that I first
learned to explain why e to the negative
x squared arises in the central limit
theorem has to do with 48 transforms and
the convolution theorem and it's nice
enough don't get me wrong but what I'd
like to try is to share a more
Elementary description that's based on
this circular symmetry the hope is that
together with this video it offers a
more visceral satisfaction for why that
particular function arises and that
maybe it offers something which would
finally address the incredulity from our
statistician's friend
[Music]
oh and uh one final footnote here after
making a patreon post about this
particular project one Patron who's a
mathematician named Kevin EGA shared
something completely delightful that I
had never seen before which is that if
you apply this integration trick in
higher Dimensions it lets you derive the
formulas for volumes of higher
dimensional spheres it's a very fun
exercise I'm leaving the details up on
the screen for any viewers who are
comfortable with integration by parts
thank you very much to Kevin for sharing
that one and thanks to all patrons by
the way both for the support of the
channel and also for all the feedback
you offer on the early drafts of videos
[Music]
foreign